welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
that always
numbs his hand before smashing it
because it's the best way to release
yourself
shout out to all the men out there that
got that joke now the latest entry
the universe is indifferent has a lot to
talk about and throughout this video
we're going to be going over our
thoughts
theories and the things that you might
have missed there will be heavy spoilers
here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
out episode 7 yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
please drop a thumbs up if you're
enjoying our breakdowns and don't forget
to subscribe to the channel to keep
up to date with our thoughts on the show
without the way thank you for clicking
this
now let's get into our breakdown of snow
episode 7.
okay so as always with snowpiercer we
get a sort of
cold opening pun intended that shows
things from the perspective of a certain
passenger
this time it's lj who divulges her
personal thoughts on the human condition
she states that every person in the
world believes that they are the center
of the universe
but that the universe is actually
completely indifferent to us
which ties into the title this is also
referenced at the end of the episode
with the song bad religion which i'll
talk about in just a bit
but yeah it's very clear that
everything's sort of one-sided with
people believing that they're important
whilst other people don't really care at
all now apart from that subtext
clip-wise there's not much else to take
from it other than that her parents are
now looked down upon by those in first
because she was never brought to justice
we also see that zara has a scan of her
baby
whilst leighton bunks up with josie he's
really got two birds with one bone
and i'll discuss how this might ruin his
revolution later in the video
leighton is clearly a big danger and we
cut to the front carriage where melanie
and the other engineers
discuss how bad it could be if the
secret comes out
as predicted mel uses miles as a weapon
and announces over the intercom that
he's been selected to replace the member
of staff that was killed last week
leighton of course hears this and though
it seems like melanie has now got him as
an ace up a sleeve
i actually think it'll backfire as she's
given someone from the tail
full access to the train now what's
interesting about this is that
ruth sneaks into the hospitality room
and sees her announcing this
apparently speaking the words of wilford
however she doesn't have any notes
or even connection to him at all and you
can sort of tell by the expression on
her face that
she's questioning what's going on over
the last couple of weeks
she slowly started to to second guess
melanie
or rather wilfred more and more and the
penny is clearly starting to drop
commander gray begins sort of charming
her later in the episode
and the two arrange a date with each
other they are clearly going to form an
alliance along with the folgers
because at this point they all want
melanie out we have said that gray
did clearly start to suspect something
was up with mel
and it's nice that we can sort of gather
he's been working behind the scenes
plotting and scheming away
whilst we haven't really seen it in the
episodes in the prisoner car
melanie inspects the drawers and learns
that several bags of suspension drugs
were stolen
this was likely john who we know is a
dealer and was in the car by himself
due to best knocking him out there aware
of where the main source of the narcotic
comes from
she calls up the janitor and questions
him now i didn't even know this but this
is the same guy that played dr yinsen
and iron man
i've legit seen that movie about 50
times and didn't even realize it was the
same person
and i meant to be doing thorough
breakdowns yikes now it's clear that the
way melanie operates is that she likes
to hold things over people's head
and she lets them get away with it for
so long because she'll always have
something in her back pocket
the janitor clearly thought he was
low-key but melanie just needed him in
the black market as a rising ears
so if she ever needed information she
could threaten him in order to get what
she wants
we also see that he doesn't have any
calluses on his hands
i think this confirms our theory that he
wasn't actually a janitor on the outside
and was likely a gangster they don't say
that for deafnet but yeah
clearly this guy wasn't working with a
mop and bucket and he infiltrated the
black market pretty easily
running it in a way that has kept him in
power he makes a deal with melanie to
hand over leighton and leighton is
smuggled to the nightcore to me audrey
i think the series is kind of showing
its budget at this point
as they only really ever have seven cars
and they jump back and forth between
them
i think they should have held off
perhaps showing all of the cars early on
as we haven't really had any surprises
since the first couple of episodes
and in my opinion it's kind of robbed us
of seeing just how weird and wonderful
the train can truly get
in the classroom car miles is given an
orange as bennett goes to collect him
for his new duty
clearly they don't get much fruit on
snowpiercer so this
is a great great joy to the lad now
symbolically
orange is a color that represents the
energy of red and the happiness of
yellow
as a fruit it also represents the sun
something that the tail
never had access to so this passing of
fruit
metaphorically shows that miles will be
moving away from it
into an area that will provide it in
plentiful amounts the class
also read the book a giraffe called
uranium and this
is a story about a giraffe that travels
from the east coast of africa to canada
it stops off at many places along the
way and
i think this book was selected because
it represents snow pierce's journey
around the planet
miles ends up being sick and in the
night car
leighton begins his insurrection audrey
initially doesn't want to help
but after she realizes how a strike was
pretty much sidelined by the crisis
she gathers the troops miles is taken to
the clinic where josie poses as a nurse
and this allows her to talk to him it
turns out that the orange was drugged
and this was in order to give him a
message she tells miles to prepare for
the revolution
and i love how in the background you can
see the teacher flirting with bennett
i don't know if you catched it but as
bennett goes after josie
you can hear her saying tell me about
your engine
tell me about your engine it's a great
quite a funny moment
um and i love when they kind of throw
weird little sound effects and ad-libs
into the background of scenes as
yeah nice little nice little bit of
comedy there now it might not be
the best chat up line but i'll tell you
who does have them
commander gray who whines and dines ruth
in the
in the aquarium caught the restaurant
car anyway we learned that everyone on
board snowpiercer
boarded two by two except for ruth this
is clearly a noah's ark metaphor
and the train itself is often referred
to as the great ark
showing that it was built to save
humanity now this has never been
said but it does make me wonder if
wilford is seen as such a deity in
profit
because he's made himself look like a
modern day noah
we also learned that ruth had a being
being kendall before the world collapsed
kendall is an area in the lake district
in england and i've actually stayed in a
bnb there before
so this was a cool little touch by the
creative team that i definitely
enjoyed now bnb is a bed and breakfast
in case you don't know
and it shows how she got a job in the
hospitality section
one day wilfred came into her bed and
breakfast and because
ruth looked after him he gave her a job
on this spot
we also learned that commander gray's
wife died two years ago
and though he is interested in ruth he
also wants to discuss
overthrowing melanie elsewhere melanie
waits in zara's room
and she comes to her with a deal she
knows that she's pregnant
and threatens her unborn baby in
exchange for leighton's life
zara betrays josie and melanie takes her
captive which we'll talk about in just a
bit
but yeah it's a big big scene leighton
meets with the key characters in third
and they talk about how they want to
create an equal system on the train
rather than a select few living in
luxury whilst others starve
he mentions a way to open all the doors
on the train which is clearly
miles so this shows that things are
heading that way he revealed to them
that melanie is in fact masquerading as
wilfred
and in the tale melanie interrogates
josie
who does something i really wasn't
expecting she full on doesn't give
an f divulging that she knows the truth
about melanie
so she knows she won't be let go i
really felt bad for josie
who goes out like a champion now one
thing that melanie says
is that she also wants snow psa to be a
certain way
however it simply hasn't been built to
function like that
there's no possible way it can continue
if things are equal
and i think that this is something
that's often brought up when discussing
the modern world
like the train we are often said to be
too far into things to turn back and
thus
melanie has been forced to keep things
the way that they are in order to allow
everyone to survive melanie begins to
torture her to get the truth on where
leighton is
and leighton goes to the janitor to
discuss an alliance as he owns all a
black market
he refuses to hand latent over but also
turns against their unity
preferring to keep things the way that
they are where he's in a position of
power
rather than sharing it melanie unable to
handle what she's doing to josie
goes to be sick and then bess goes into
the hospitality court where josie passes
on a message
that zara betrayed them but miles is
still a part of the team
ruth goes to warn melanie about the
folgers but in her anger she
shuts her down unless it's likely that
she's going to be overthrown by the
group
who are forming a coup to make matters
worse josie almost kills her
and it's revealed that bess gave her the
freeze gun which she used to destroy her
hand so she could get out of the
handcuffs
josie almost kills her and after how bad
melanie has been this episode
i really really wanted her too the pipe
for the gun is pulled off the wall
and this begins to freeze the cabin
melanie manages to escape
but josie is killed during it and grey
gets angered by melanie carrying out an
interrogation without him
and she brings miles up to the front who
we of course know is planning to open
all of the doors for the tale
the episode ends with leighton screaming
over the death of josie
whilst the song bad religion by frank
ocean is sung by audrey
the song is about a man that has
unrequited love for someone
and this ties into the title the
universe is indifferent
he obsesses over them but they don't
love him back
and thus this is seen as a bad religion
clearly
this is a comment on those that worship
wilfred and the train
but obviously doesn't care for them as
there's so much injustice
and inequality i think this song being
sung
is sort of a way to say goodbye to josie
but it's also been put in place to say
goodbye to the way that things on the
train currently are
the secret is now out and melanie has
made too many enemies
so the only way that things can go for
her now are really quite bad
we learned that layton waits for lj in
the hypnosis room
and he actually has a job for her
clearly layton wants to use her ability
to access the train
but also she will spread the truth about
melanie
i actually thought that she already knew
it due to torturing wilford informants
but obviously not now she will likely go
to her parents and tell them
and as they already wanted to overthrow
melanie for
for telling them no several times this
will be a bit of information that they
can use to weaponize
pretty much the entire train against her
one of her allies ruth now hates her
guts
and yeah things aren't looking good for
her we have just three episodes left
unless uh i don't think she's gonna be
in a position
of power much longer that was another
brilliant episode
and shout out to josie yeah rest in
peace now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the seventh episode and
what your theories are
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown on the series so far if you've
missed
anything at all now if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat just after the
show either follow us at heavyspoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
every month we give away free movies to
people are subscribed to the channel
and this month you come in the mcu
infinity saga boxset and all you have to
do is comment on a video and make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on the more videos you comment on the
more you have a chance of winning so
make sure you get involved
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of july and the set will be
shipped out from then to if it gets the
price
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
you